we have with us tonight one of the most
please welcome dr. Ruth
thank you what I'd like to do in this
talk and I hope I don't go on too long
is to remind people of a few simple
truths that are signed often forgets and
the first of these is that being
skeptical about global warming does not
by itself make one a good scientist nor
does endorsing global warming make one
per se a poor scientist and one of the
most difficult things I think for
someone who is actively involved in the
scientific community is to realize in my
case for instance that most of the
atmospheric scientists who I respect to
endorse global warming
the important point however is that the
science that they do that I respect is
not about global warming endorsing
global warming just makes their lives
easier the second point is that most
arguments about global warming boiled
down to science versus Authority for
much of the public authority will
generally win since they do not wish to
deal with science my third point is
related to the second point and that is
that the success of environmentalism
with respect to Authority also gives the
alarm movement control over carrots and
sticks which in turn is what makes it so
convenient for scientists to go along
the process of co-opting science on
behalf of a
movement has had an extraordinarily
corrupting influences on science
especially since the issue has been a
major motivation for funding most
funding for climate would not be there
without this issue in any event one of
the things about impacts is that they
generally are dependent on regional
forecasts such forecasts are no better
than guesses now that might seem like a
problem to you from a scientific
perspective but from a propagandistic or
impact perspective that's wonderful
because guesses have the advantage of
allowing anything to be projected and
they are so used what can be done well
here I'll turn to a variety of proposals
both naive and perhaps less naive the
most obvious point I think is to
persevere we shouldn't give up we should
try to better understand the science and
in particular to emphasize logic which
ultimately has to trump alleged
Authority actually the science isn't all
that hard John Sununu
who will be speaking at this meeting
offered an easily appreciated example of
positive and
feedback I like this one he suggested in
your car the gas and brake pedals act as
negative feedbacks to reduce speed when
you are going too fast and to increase
it when you're going too slow the
example of a positive feedback would be
if someone were to reverse the position
of the pedals without informing you so
that now you would be increasing your
speed when you're going too fast and
slowing down when you're going too slow
now on the face of it this does not seem
like a reasonable way to build a system
and yet alarming predictions depend
critically on the fact that models have
large positive feedbacks the crucial
question is whether nature actually
behaves that way the answer I would
suggest is unambiguously no now let's
see how one can test this and this is
amazing because we're arguing about
temperatures and we're arguing about all
this but the issue has always been
referred to as the greenhouse effect can
one test that by itself in the common
though somewhat inaccurate picture of
the greenhouse effect greenhouse
substances they're mainly thin high
clouds and water vapor but they also
include carbon dioxide methane freons
and other things acts as a blanket it
inhibits the emission of infrared or
heat radiation we know that in the
absence of dean box in which what are
these feedbacks say that water vapor and
clouds act to amplify the effect of
added co2 in these things if we
increased
temperature that will lead to a certain
increase in this heat radiation with
positive feedbacks this amount of
radiation will be reduced the idea here
is just in terms of the blanket imagery
the blanket has gotten thicker current
models indeed behave this way if you
force a current model with observed sea
surface temperature
it emits very little thermal radiation
as the temperature goes up getting
people including many scientists to
understand this is crucial once it is
understood the silliness of the whole
issue becomes evident unfortunately
though those who are committed to
warming alarm as either a vehicle for a
postmodern coup d'etat or for illicit
profits will obviously try to obfuscate
matters I would suggest that one useful
tactic would be to have a major campaign
to get thousands of scientists to resign
from professional societies that have
taken unrepresentative stance on the
warming issue while making the reason
for the resignation unambiguous and
public this would in my opinion be far
more effective than simply collecting
thousands of signatures for petitions
the global warming issue has done much
to set back climate science in
particular the notion that climate is
one-dimensional which is to say that it
is totally described by some fictitious
global mean temperature and some single
gross forcing Allah increased co2 is
grotesque in its oversimplification
finally I would suggest that however
grim things may appear I think will
eventually win
against anthropogenic global warming
along simply because we are right and
they are wrong but at least this
audience should be aware that this does
nothing to mitigate the failure of
nature to properly follow the models the
fact that you have record-breaking years
does not tell you that the trend was not
there and when I hear that argument
commonly presented you should be
prepared to reject it to claim otherwise
betray is either gross ignorance or
grosser dishonesty unfortunately when it
comes to global warming hysteria neither
has been in short supply thank you